[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler d'une
maladie inquiétante qui se répand sur la
planète
non il ne s'agit pas de lakovic 19 il
s'agit de l'infobésité une sorte
d'avalanche de contagion d'information
qui fait que nous sommes que vous êtes
gaver goinfrer d'information à c'est un
luxe c'est un bénéfice notamment pour le
savoir et pour la démocratie mais c'est
aussi un risque est en tout cas c'est
une première dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
allez remontons le temps et restons en
france nous sommes le 14 juillet 1789 il
se passe un petit quelque chose du côté
de la place de la bastille la grande
prison est prise d'assaut
elle est saccagée ravagé ruiner les
prisonniers sont libérés à quelques
kilomètres de là à versailles le roi
louis saez n'être au courant de rien
personne ne lui dit il n'y a pas
d'information le soir avant de se
coucher dans son journal il écrit
14 juillet 1789 deux points rien avant
sont un peu dans le temps
nous sommes le 9 septembre 1843 victor
hugo a fait un voyage très agréable en
espagne avec sa maîtresse juliette
drouet il remonte par la côte atlantique
il fait beau encore en ce début
d'automne
il arrive à rochefort il s'assoit au
café de l'europe sur la terrasse il
ouvre un journal qui est là qui
s'appelle le siècle il lit les rubriques
politique internationale fait divers
dans les faits divers il apprend que sa
fille léopoldine quelques jours plus tôt
s'est noyé en faisant de la barque avec
son fiancé
personne ne l'avait prévenue aucun média
aucun téléphone
victor hugo ne le savais pas il a appris
par hasard des jours plus tard
continuerons à nous rapprocher de nous
nous sommes en 1970 pierre lazareff et
le patron du plus grand quotidien
français france soir qui tire à des
millions d'exemplaires qui tire en
permanence france-soir dernière édition
cris les vendeurs dans la rue parce que
toutes les deux heures il y à une
nouvelle édition
et puis le patron lazarev se rend compte
que ça commence à décliner france soir
il se demande pourquoi ils se
renseignent il étudie
et il comprend il a cette phrase
tellement éloquent de notre modernité
avant quand il y avait une nouvelle les
français descendait dans la rue pour
acheter
france soir maintenant il remonte chez
eux pour allumer la télévision
rapprochons nous encore nous sommes le
25 juin 2009 un réseau social
on ne les appelle pas encore ainsi
commence à faire parler de lui on
il n'est pas très sérieux mais enfin il
est sympathique il s'appelle twitter le
gazouillis et 40 ans ce jour là sur
twitter et bien une fois de plus parce
que on entend cette fausse nouvelle très
souvent une fois de plus on nous apprend
que michael jackson est mort
sauf que cette fois c'est vrai et c'est
pas par une agence de presse c'est pas
par un grand network
ce n'est pas par un journal c'est par ce
réseau social que l'info aura été sortis
avant d'être bien sûr vérifier est
répandu sur toute la planète
l'infobésité est arrivé de tous les
côtés
l'information vient à vous vous n'avez
plus à aller chercher l'information
elle vous inondent elle se répand elle
est dans votre poche elle fait bip bip
vous la regardez vous ne pouvez pas y
échapper
l'information a pris le pouvoir sur
l'informer il est temps que l'informer
se défendent et fasse attention à trier
le vrai du faux la bonne information de
la mauvaise ah bah tiens puisque c'est
comme ça je vais vous donner une vraie
information importante
la véritable histoire de l'écharpé rouge
je vous la donne parce que par le plus
grand des hasards et on ne l'a pas fait
exprès c'est ici au palais des glaces
que tout a commencé il ya maintenant
plus de 30 ans je participe et un jeune
concours d'étudiants on faisait ce qui
ne s'appelait pas encore à l'époque le
stand up on faisait des sketches on
imite m
moi j'étais à l'époque étudiant à
normale sup j'ai je suis venu faire un
sketch sur ce qui me passionnait la
politique j'ai fait un sketch sur
françois mitterrand
évidemment je me suis un peu déguisé
j'ai mis un chapeau et l'écharpé rouge
meeting de françois mitterrand et il se
trouve que j'ai gagné ce concours
le président du jury marc jolivet
humoriste m'a remis le trophée à la fin
de la soirée il m'a dit je nomme cette
écharpe rouge vous porte bonheur gardez
là c'est un peu comme un rideau de
théâtre pour vous j'ai pris au mot
depuis ce jour là j'ai gardé l'écharpé
rouge
incroyable n'est ce pas qu'on se
retrouve ici au palais des glaces plus
de 30 ans après
vous donne cette histoire elle est belle
mais elle est complètement fausse je
viens de l'inventer
elle est crédible puisque nous sommes
dans les lieux puis que tout coller mais
elle est fausse et je fais ça souvent
quand je vais en province se parler à
des lycéens à chaque fois j'invente la
véritable histoire de l'écharpé rouge
toujours lié à leur ville à leur
environnement et à la fin je leur dis
que c'est faux sauf que quand je leur
dis que c'est faux comme l'histoire a
pris deux ou trois minutes
et bien certains dans la classe l'ont
déjà twitté l'ont déjà mis sur leur page
facebook l'ont déjà envoyer à leurs amis
à saillé jeu c'est l'histoire l'écharpé
rouge
bon c'est pas grave ce n'est que
l'écharpé rouge mais ça pourrait avoir
des conséquences plus graves
par exemple je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de la dépêche dance nous
sommes le 13 juillet 1870 le l'empereur
de prusse à une envie c'est se mêler du
remplacement du roi d'espagne le trône
est vacant il pousse un de ses cousins
owens hollande
mais la france ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille pas question que l'allemagne
choisissent le roi d'espagne
la france intervient l'empereur décide
de faire la paix dit d'accord très bien
je retire la candidature d'un de mes
parents nous ne choisirons pas et il
envoie à son chancelier bismarck un
télégramme dix ans on apaise les choses
avec la france bismarck ne l'entend pas
de cette oreille il a envie d'en
découdre
alors il téléguident un article dans un
journal allemand
un article plus dur qui explique que la
france s'est mal comporté l'article fait
l'objet d'un autre article dans un
journal français qui s'offusquent à ce
moment là une agence allemande fait une
dépêche la fameuse dpj dems pour dire
que ça ne se passera pas comme ça
et elle raconte comment l'ambassadeur de
france a rendu visite à l'empereur
d'allemagne
la dépêche est envoyé en france elle est
traduite et le mot hadji tente qui veut
dire aide de camp en allemand et traduit
en français par le mot adjudant donc
pour les allemands c'est l'aide de camp
de l'empereur qui a accompagné
l'ambassadeur pour les français c'est un
simple adjudant qui a été chargé de
congédier
l'ambassadeur de france les choses
s'enveniment
ça donne la guerre de 1870 ça donne la
fin de l' empire du second empire de
napoléon iii
vous voyez une information
bien présente et mal présentés peut
changer le cours de l'histoire
alors contre cela qu'y at il d'abord
plusieurs remèdes le premier remède
c'est de se méfier des belles paroles
que ce soit pour parler d'une écharpe
rouge qui n'a pas d'importance ou du
trône d'espagne gorgias dans la célèbre
fable racontée par platon dit à socrate
mais moi le meilleur des médecins mais
nous tous les deux face aux malades
nous leur parlerons et tu verras que les
malades ne croiront mois et non le
médecin parce que l'art de la rhétorique
est supérieure à tous les arts et que
voyons nous aujourd'hui et vient des
médecins qui parfois ne sont pas bien
écouté alors que des beaux parleurs des
charlatans parfois médecins aussi
parfois politiques ont les faveurs des
foules la rhétorique la manière de dire
transmettre être le média il faut
toujours s'en méfier mais s'en méfier ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut le combattre et
le renier non il faut juste développer
l'esprit critique
l'esprit critique ça se forment sa
s'entraîne comme un muscle disait
descartes
oui l'esprit critique c'est non pas
renié l'information mais faire de la
gymnastique avec l'information
est-ce qu'il faut croire ou ne pas
croire surtout ne pas croire on n'est
pas dans le domaine de la fois une
information ça ne se croit pas ça se
considèrent qu est ce que ça veut dire
considérer d'abord considéré c'est avoir
du respect
j'ai de la considération pour une
personne quand il ya une information je
la considère je fais partie de mon temps
je dois y prêter attention
j'ai du respect pour la formation mais
considéré ça veut dire aussi examinées
je considère la situation
je regarde tous les recoins et puis à la
fin considéré ça veut dire se faire une
opinion
je considère que cette idée est bonne je
considère que tu as tort considéré c'est
la bonne attitude face à une information
ensuite dans un deuxième temps il faut
toujours se poser la même question qui
parlent une information c'est du verbe
ou une image qui est un autre langage
avec un émetteur et un récepteur qui est
l'émetteur d'où parle tu disais les
gauchistes au moment de mai 68 et il
n'avait pas tort quand on parle ont
repris
quand quelqu'un son média sa famille de
pensée ses intérêts sa propre
subjectivité il n'ya pas d'objectivité
on peut être honnête on ne peut pas être
objectif dans une information il faut tu
avoir disait jean jacques servan
shreiber
le fondateur de l'express il faut avoir
la subjectivité des intéressés la
subjectivité c'est moi ma sensibilité
mes convictions c'est bien c'est ma
richesse mais il faut qu'elles soient
désintéressés quand je suis journaliste
si elle est intéressée parce que je veux
aider une entreprise et d un homme
politique je ne fais plus journaliste je
suis militant mais si je suis subjectif
mais désintéressée là je fais mon
travail qui parle
celui qui parle est il des intéressés et
ça en enquêtant un peu on le voit très
vite on voit bien qui signe les papiers
on voit bien d'où et l'émetteur ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il ment ça veut dire
qu'il nous donne son point de vue le
point de vue jean-jacques
servan-schreiber disait aussi c'était
devenu la devise de l'express dire la
vérité telle que nous la voyons telle
que nous la voyons
après bien sûr c'est le reporter qui va
sur le terrain qu'ils voient et qui
raconte ce qu'il a vu 100 m le
commentaire juste ce qu'il a vu mais ce
convoi peut être trompeur telle que nous
la voyons ça veut dire aussi avoir un
point de vue c'est notre point de vue
nous voyons les choses comme cela et
c'est très honorable
telle est la subjectivité désintéressé
une usine de chaussures explose en chine
un journal va titrer dramatique accident
en chine 50 ouvriers tués ça sera une
agence mais l'humanité journal
communiste va titrer le capitalisme
mondialisé tue 50 ouvriers en chine à un
journal américain va titrer la politique
industrielle de pékin tu es que va
écrire le journal de pékin pour répondre
aux américains rien parce que pour pékin
il n'y a pas eu d'accident
il n'y a pas d'enfants qui travaillent
dans les usines de chaussures en chine
vous voyez le même fait des points de
vue différents
pour se prémunir contre les mensonges
que faut-il faire
tout lire c'est le remède suivant le
pluralisme a évidemment autant de
l'infobésité tout lire ça devient
compliqué ça devient même impossible
donc il faut éviter l'erreur suivante
qui est de lire n'importe quoi puisqu'on
ne peut pas tout lire
on lit n'importe quoi là premier site
internet qui se présentent la première
rumeur sur un réseau social on la lit et
on la croit
double erreur non tout lire c'est lire
le plus possible c'est être dans le
pluralisme
tiens c'est pas mal cet article du
figaro mais qu'en dit l'humanité
tiens c'est intéressant cet article de
libération mais qu'en dit l'express le
pluralisme
c'est à dire déguster le grand festin de
l'information en picorant dans tous les
plats le pluralisme
c'est le meilleur vaccin non contre le
mensonge y en aura toujours mais contre
l'unique vérité contre la subjectivité
intéressé le militantisme
écoutons plusieurs voies avant de forger
notre opinion et ça c'est la dernière
étape
oh c'est très bien de regarder les
informations de les considérer c'est
encore mieux d'avoir plusieurs sources
d'information pour les comparer les
mettre en compétition mais ce n'est pas
suffisant le troisième étage de la fusée
du citoyen du 21e siècle
informer c'est de se former avec tout ce
que j'ai lu avec tout ce que j'ai
entendu
qu'est ce que je crois est-ce que je
crois quelque chose est-ce que j'ai une
conviction est ce que j'ai une idée
qu'est ce que je suis prêt à faire pour
la défendre
à ce moment-là citoyen n'est pas
seulement informé il est fort mais c'est
à dire éduqués pour prendre sa part pour
prendre sa place dans le débat citoyen
dans le grand tumulte de l'information
qui n'est finalement que le bruit de
fond de ce que l'on appelle la
démocratie de ce que l'on peut appeler
même le genre humain l'humanité le vivre
ensemble
voilà ce qu'il faut faire ne pas croire
mais considéré faire attention à savoir
qui parle
d'où ils parlent écouté plusieurs voies
pour savoir d'où elle parle
une fois qu'on a écouté assez et on ne
peut pas le faire tous les jours sur
tous les sujets c'est vrai savoir ce que
je pense est ce que je pense
et quand je pense quand je suis sur qu
est ce que je dis qu'est ce que je fais
où vais-je renvoyer transmettre la balle
de l'information dans la quête de la
vérité
ça c'est le travail du citoyen le
citoyen mais un bon citoyen que s'il est
bien formée que s'il est bien informé
merci
[Musique]